this is robert langdon the suspect  called him i teach a symbology  did this person say what he wants he  wants me to locate an ancient portal  buried within the capitol  then that means something to you didn't  it till i saw that  it's your dad that had his ring  tonight  the people who took him  want me to find a piece of a very old  puzzle revenue most like a runic  variation smart people  it's upside down  i have something  dad said that it's secrecy was more  valuable than his life  i'm coming with you  one pill is lifted  only to reveal another  you were told to do it alone  he has my father he has a literal  assassin and that's what it's going to  take to get me to stop okay mom  i want to know how far robert langton  has gotten  it's a cipher for all who seek must also  fall  yeah i'm more of a sudoku guy  i can't stop  it's just begun  [Music]  you